I generally try not to dip into YouTube
drama but sometimes
sometimes the irony is too perfect
[Music]
hello folks um for those of you who are
expecting the finale of Doctor Who flux
as a take two Doctor Who reviewed today
that's gonna go to next week I didn't
want to risk bumping the plan Saturday
video partly because that is a pride
themed video and that's the last
Saturday of pride month so I didn't want
to balance that not to mention
um while this is a story with way longer
legs than I thought it was going to have
which is why I haven't talked about it
uh well part of why I haven't talked
about it prior to this
um I didn't want to risk waiting that
much longer so you know things moved
around a little but don't worry it's all
still coming anyways so
really don't talk about YouTube drama
very much as a rule of thumb when I talk
about YouTube I'm complaining about the
site itself the algorithm ignoring me
some nonsense that they're pulling with
stuff like the mid-roll credits changes
in policy and just general idiocy by the
company itself
I try very hard not to indulge in
YouTube drama between creators
because wow as lucrative as it is and it
is lucrative one of my five most viewed
videos is of YouTube drama specifically
in regards to channel awesome there is a
reason that other than the two channel
awesome videos I did I really don't
touch this topic which is it very easily
becomes a feedback loop of you do a
video dissecting some drama it's very
easy for you then to get sucked into it
and then discuss around it or to be
attacked by the people who are
supporting the person that the drama
surrounding even though even if you're
only trying to summarize it like it gets
very messy very quickly and it's just
one of the uglier sides of uh of this
platform so even in cases where like
I've had other creators specifically try
and come at me I've only ever done a
response to that once and so I don't
even really do that but this one
you know I initially I thought I didn't
have a lot to say but then somebody
asked me about it on Twitch uh follow me
on Twitch if you aren't already and I
realized starting to talk about it I've
actually got more to say than I thought
now I am going to be going over some of
the basic bullet points of what actually
happened that kicked off all the drama
to contextualize and give you some
background but if you are looking for a
comprehensive analysis or timeline of
what has gone on around the YouTube
channel Illuminati you are not going to
find it here I am not interested in
cataloging every single offense or
detailing every single aspect of this
what I am interested in is after going
over the fundamentals putting it in the
context of YouTube scandals in general
to look at how this one's different from
others because
based off some of the stuff that has
happened it's playing out in an
interesting way and I think I know why
but I still find it interesting to talk
about
so
let's cover the basics as I said this is
not going to be comprehensive there are
some great channels out there that have
been doing videos ongoing as things have
been unraveling
um I found this video by Savvy Wright's
books to be a very good overview video
uh generally speaking if you want
something like that but there's plenty
of stuff out there people have been
talking about this for a while which as
I said was part of the reason why I
thought I might not talk about it
because this has been an ongoing thing
for about two months now
these kinds of things don't last that
long as a rule especially if the person
that they're about isn't continually
feeding into the into the whole drama
situation which
arguably uh Blairs on AKA Illuminati is
not doing but we'll get to all that
it's kind of fun to go over how this all
happened because this started
for these stupidest possible reason this
is really dumb how all this started
so what are we talking about
as I said the YouTube channel Illuminati
which if you are not familiar is known
for doing breakdowns of the falling
apart of companies of um doing anti-mlm
multi-level marketing videos talking
about the hazards of those business
models often in focusing on specific
figures at the center of business
related controversies people who ran
their companies into the ground tank
their own Public Image
etc etc
um I actually had watched some of her
stuff before the main reason I kind of
fell off it was not because it wasn't
good but she cranked stuff out at such a
she basically puts out content faster
than I particularly want to take in that
kind of content
um and that's not to make it sound like
she was doing shoddy or or slap Dash or
hastily put together work she has a team
of people she has researchers she has uh
an editing team she had a crew of people
which was why she was able to produce
stuff as rapidly as she did but you know
I watched some of her stuff for a little
bit but then kind of felt like you know
you you talk about stuff more often than
I want to hear this kind of stuff talked
about and I kind of bounced off after
that but since uh Illuminati was a name
that I recognized when this uh whole
mess blew up it did Ping my radar
and it's been really interesting as I
said it started for a very stupid reason
which means fittingly this all started
on Twitter
so on April 20th of this year Illuminati
put out a tweet accusing another YouTube
channel legal eagle
of stealing a particular editing
technique from her videos particularly
have to do with the way in which text
was highlighted in a document on screen
during the video
now
this is uh
uh weird for a number of reasons the
first one being that um
you can't really steal a visual
signifier like that like unless it's a
specific thing that you've trademarked
like for instance
um lots of movies or TV shows for like
their titles or one I will have a custom
made font just for that thing just for
them and those are often trademarked as
part of a brand so like something like
that if somebody was using You could
argue that they are stealing it if it's
not somehow being tied back to you uh in
its use but something just like an
editing technique to highlight text
that
it's just an editing technique the basis
by which Illuminati was making this
claim of theft in
very large sarcasm quotes was because
apparently one of legal Eagle's editors
had reached out to one of her editors
going hey how is it that you do that in
your videos what plugins do you use
which should be your first thing that
this wasn't stolen it's just asking what
plugins to the ending software are used
unless uh Illuminati and her team
personally programmed those uh those
plugins and never made them available to
the public they're just asking what tool
you're using that that's not theft
anyways on that basis Illuminati said
that she had started she had then looked
at some illegal Eagles videos saw what
she considered to be the same
highlighting technique just in a
different color and accused uh the
channel of stealing her approach to
things which again
it's not really a thing because even
even if they were using the exact same
plugin which you can't really prove like
it it doesn't matter like seriously if
you know anything about video editing
ask 10 different editors to accomplish a
certain style of thing for you they will
probably do it in 10 at least slightly
different ways there are a million ways
to accomplish the exact same thing so
the whole thing was very strange
and she really ended up with egg on her
face when two things were pointed out
the first was that the editor who was
inquiring and like they did that
actually happened they weren't asking on
behalf of legal eagle because even
though this editor did do work for legal
eagle they also did their own stuff and
they were asking for a video that they
were making for themselves and as the
legal eagle YouTube channel pointed out
they'd actually been doing that kind of
text highlighting for quite some time
well predating when this editor asked
about it
so uh
Illuminati kind of had egg on her face
immediately now
in kind of what should be considered
this should have been the end of it
um she apparently got in touch with
legal eagle there was a bit of a back
and forth there came to be an
understanding she put out something of
an apology
um and in which she said like look I I
went off the handle I went off what my
editors were telling me that they
thought they saw I acted rashly I didn't
look into it enough which
if you're going to accuse somebody of
effectively plagiarism maybe you should
check and make sure you know what you're
talking about but okay she acted
rationally left to a conclusion said
something stupid
well that's it right
no uh no it is not because uh around the
same time in kind of pointing out the
irony H bomber guy another uh quite
large YouTube channel he pointed out
some potential plagiarism on the part of
illuminati uh because you see each
bomber guy a little while back did a
video on sort of the start of the modern
anti-vaxx movement and in association
with that he did an awful lot of
research into the journalism and
research and reporting of one Brian dear
and so uh H bomber guy was very familiar
with Brian deer's work and he
um put side by side some of Brian deer's
reporting and a section of um
Illuminati's video on the start of the
anti-vaxx movement and it was quoted
verbatim then in 1995 he was suspended
for practicing medicine I might pay a
ten thousand dollar fine for his misuse
of misprescribing of controlled drugs
then in 1995 he was suspended from
practicing medicine and made to pay a
ten thousand dollar fine for his misuse
of prescribing controlled drugs and it
sounded like she was presenting these
words as her own and so that that didn't
help it's not a good look when uh
somebody goes hey uh you just accuse
somebody of plagiarism but uh what's
this now she would have a response to
that but but that got rolled into a
response to a number of other things
because this is when the thing that
um sort of lit the spark that would
become the bomb of all this uh happened
which is there's another Creator who I'm
actually not familiar with uh with at
all because I knew Illuminati I know
legally I I say I know not personally
but I'm familiar with Illuminati
familiar with legally go familiar with h
bomber guy but another Creator called
The Click was apparently asked about
this kind of drama and in particular
about
Illuminati's behavior and quickness to
uh condemn and lash out because
apparently Illuminati worked with The
Clique and a number of other creators
some of which are going to come up in a
minute on a collaborative Channel called
sad milk which I'm not going to go into
exactly what that was because I had
never heard of it before any of this
happened and the exact nature of that
channel doesn't actually really matter
not for my purposes so the click
basically did a Twitter thread saying
look I don't interact with Illuminati
anymore we haven't really spoken at all
um and it's because this kind of
behavior is actually very typical of her
and it's why we no longer collaborate
and why I don't really talk to her at
all anymore now
one could argue whether or not the click
should have laid out as much as he did
and whether or not that was stirring
drama it's it's a little bit subjective
I would say on that one could make that
argument certainly it was prompted by
his followers asking for his thoughts on
what was going on he wasn't obligated to
respond he could have just said that's
really no like I don't I have no opinion
this has nothing to do with me but he
did take the opportunity to kind of say
his piece a little bit of that he
basically did not have a good working
relationship with Illuminati and also on
Twitter The Click was backed up by
another Creator who was part of sad milk
who named Wonderstruck who basically
backed up the click stories and said
yeah that is very much how she is and
has been
so then the thing that that just blew
the whole thing up happy
Illuminati put out a response video
now it starts out well enough
she addresses the stuff that happened
with legal eagle which had pretty much
already been resolved on Twitter so but
she really reiterates all that she talks
about H bomber guys
um suggestion that she may plagiarize
Brian dear her explanation for that was
it hadn't been her intention to present
Brian deer's words as if they were her
own she was directly quoting them but
says that she didn't do a good job of
making it clear that what she was saying
was a quote from his reporting instead
of her own words which
possible
I mean like it's sloppy work if that is
ultimately the case but like that is
possible to have happened
so
that stuff was addressed well enough
then she decided to respond to the stuff
said by the click
and by Wonderstruck
and this is where everything went to
hell
because rather than just responding to
what they said about working with her or
indeed just going
I'm I feel bad that they felt the need
to comment on this at all I'd like to
think that whatever happened between us
is both
strictly between us and in the past so I
would rather they hadn't said anything
but I'm not going to fuel that fire like
something like that probably would have
been the best thing she could have said
she didn't say that she didn't even
really
um focus on
um debunking or disproving anything that
they said
instead she decided to throw out
accusations of her own and pull a whole
oh you think I'm bad wait till I tell
you about these two
and I'm not going to go through it all
because it's a lot but it was some
pretty nasty stuff that she accused the
two of them of engaging with
um and the one thing that I will point
out specifically is she brought up
wonderstruck's mental health and the
state of his mental health at the time
and some struggles he was having which
is
a real move
somebody's Mental Health
it is their right to disclose that to
other people it's not yours
so
that is like the big like ah but other
than that it's like she made a lot of
allegations like that thing she
shouldn't have done regardless but she
made a lot of accusations that basically
amounted to do boy
if that's true
she uh she really is firing back against
these people
well unfortunately
um they weren't going to let that stand
and unlike Illuminati who came with some
very carefully tailored handful of
things and very carefully curated
Stories the click and Wonderstruck came
back
with a lot of receipts for how things
actually went down and also at that time
a bunch of other people started coming
out of the woodwork former employees
collaborators
um stuff was found regarding an old
boyfriend of Illuminati's all of it
pointing to the same kind of behavior
controlling
short-tempered and abusive behavior and
as I said all these other people
showed up with receipts
and Illuminati then did one thing very
smart and one thing very stupid
the smart thing she did was not put out
another video responding she's actually
gone back to business as normal on her
Channel which generally speaking with
these kinds of YouTube scandals is the
smartest thing you can do go back to the
thing that people are here for you for
go back to what they like to watch from
you don't let don't allow it to stop or
break don't give them a chance to walk
away keep doing your normal stuff at
your normal output which she has done
but it hasn't helped which is surprising
because on paper
that's the best thing she could do but
as I said she also did one of the
dumbest things she should and she could
have done especially considering the
kinds of people that she has covered
regularly on her Channel and the kinds
of behavior from these other business
people that she has profiled and the
kinds of things that they have done that
have gotten them in more trouble and
looked really bad she did one of them
which was to send a cease and desist
letter from her lawyers to I believe it
was initially Wonderstruck and then
another to another formal collaborator
of hers Oz media now I haven't mentioned
Oz media up to now in his own tweet in
which he pointed out that he had gotten
a cease and desist from her lawyers he
then mentioned in the Twitter thread I
haven't even made a video yet her
lawyers issued to him a cease and desist
that was referencing videos he was not
even in
using a seasoned desist to try and
silence criticism especially if
something that is already known to the
public
that's not a smart move
and since then and this like most of
this happened a month ago or more
but more stuff keeps coming forward
either more people have come forward
with more information or people
following this have dug up more stuff
from the past because she honestly has a
little bit of a history of behavior that
does fit into this it's just the full
picture wasn't known before people
weren't really talking the way that they
are now and it does appear to be in many
ways like what happened during a lot of
the metoo movements with people like
Bill Cosby or Harvey Weinstein which is
that there were lots of people with
stories to tell many of whom had
receipts and haven't and had evidence to
back up their version of events but
nobody wanted to be the first one to
come forward and say anything because
you risk getting stomped and on getting
stomped under the foot of a beloved and
bigger name than you and being bombarded
by their fans and
you risk standing alone and being
obliterated but
after
um I would say initially the clicks sort
of started to lay some stuff up but
definitely after she did her video
accusing the click and wonder struck of
the various things she accused them of
and them coming back and going oh hang
on a minute and laying out everything
that they had that seemed to open the
floodgates of people going oh
yeah me too and I like I actually didn't
mean to make that comparison uh to the
actual metoo movement and then use the
phrase but that really was kind of it
it's a lot easier to say that also
happened to me when you know you won't
be alone and so as I said the floodgates
have opened and they haven't really
stopped since
so that's the background
what was the Fallout well Illuminati had
around a million and a half subscribers
now she has lost over a hundred thousand
of those subscribers now just by raw
numbers that may not sound like that
much because like it's what less than 10
percent
but first of all for a channel that size
to lose that many that quickly because
it was a precipitous drop it was
immediate is uh it's not good and I'll
explain some of the reasons why even
though Again by numbers is like oh that
shouldn't mean that much of a difference
there's also the fact that she's prob
there's a good chance she's lost more
than that there are some folks who track
um the way that channels are growing and
there's been some suspicious activity uh
in the last month or so that may
indicate the use of bots to try and bump
the numbers back up things like what
looked like a growth of like a thousand
new subscribers in like a matter of
minutes which is generally pretty
suspect but even if that's being done or
even if it's not it doesn't matter it's
not enough to counteract how many
subscribers she is losing now to explain
why a hundred thousand subscribers is
actually huge even to a um channel that
had or still has actually over a million
subscribers is this
no matter what the number of subscribers
you have is
no YouTuber assumes that that's how many
views you're gonna get you'd think
logically oh this many people want to be
notified every time I put out a video
all of them will watch every video I put
out that is not the reality
that's never the reality
so what that 100
000 likely represents especially given
what happened to her views which I'm
going to come back to
that hundred thousand likely represents
her most engaged and dedicated viewers
they were probably the ones who were
coming in and watching as soon as a new
video was uploaded seeing almost
everyone that went up
they're the ones who are probably gone
because there's a lot of stuff that can
fill out a subscriber number that aren't
actually people actively engaged in your
content on a regular basis you can have
debt accounts that basically aren't used
at all anymore but they subscribe to you
at some point you can have people who
maybe only subscribe to you for certain
kinds of content so they're subscribed
to see when you upload that but they're
not going to watch everything that you
upload or sometimes if the algorithm is
feeling particularly spicy it's
distinctly possible that they're just
not sending your new videos to your
subscribers anyway because YouTube is
fun like that but yeah that hundred
thousand that's a severe
hit
and then there's what happened to her
views so
prior to all this going down
what was standard views for Illuminati
video was easily over a hundred thousand
usually several hundred thousands not
uncommon to break a million that didn't
happen all the time but it also happened
semi-regularly her videos were very
reliably very well viewed now after that
um initial uh video response they went
down a bit they were failing new videos
were failing to clear two hundred
thousand which some videos prior to that
uh to this whole thing happening
wouldn't clear 200 000 but they were the
exception more often than not but then
as more and more stuff came out as more
stuff unraveled as more people came
forward with their own stories and the
receipts to back them up
she's gone for a stretch now of multiple
videos that have not even cracked a
hundred thousand and for reference I
went back through her feed to see how
long ago was it the last time that she
failed to break a hundred thousand views
on a video and it was back in April of
2022 and it just barely failed to hit
000. some of the stuff she's putting out
now isn't even breaking 50 000. this is
a huge huge drop and it is consistent
with each new video released it's not
coming back up
and this is probably hitting a lot more
than that multiple of her regular
sponsors corporate sponsors have said
they will no longer be advertising with
her they've canceled her contracts they
pulled out with using her as someone to
be a spokesperson or to support their
content she's not only lost a lot of
subscribers but a lot of direct
financial support now
it's arguable how much or which of these
sponsors involved are abandoning her
because of the look because the look
very much right now is consistently of
somebody controlling uh abusive and very
quick to anger and some of these Brands
probably just don't want to be
associated with that others are probably
looking at the numbers dropping going
it's not worth it for us to be connected
to this person because I don't doubt
that some of these corporations if her
numbers had never dipped would be going
ah
it's worth it enough people are going to
see our stuff it's worth it but like
with numbers now as low as she's getting
she's not worth it she's not worth the
trouble now to most companies
so
why is this hitting so much harder than
the standard YouTube
Scandal or drama or uh controversy
because it is like this is lasting
longer in terms of like how much stuff
is coming out and it is hitting her
harder despite as I said her doing one
of the smartest things you can do which
is to not let it interrupt your output
and it's not helping
why not
well this is the main thing that I
wanted to focus on and putting this into
context of other similar situations to
see how it is the same or how it is
different so when we think of a lot of
YouTube controversies some of the big
ones involve names like Jake Paul or
Logan Paul I forget which one or both I
don't know or PewDiePie that's another
big one
or even some smaller scale ones uh like
when somebody like Blair white was
caught telling easily verified lies
about a trans athlete and things of that
nature these things have blown up in
these creators faces and often resulted
in multiple people doing think pieces
takedowns and even an initial loss of
some subscribers at the time but all
these people are still around
they didn't go away they took a little
hit they took a little ding at the time
but it didn't stick it wasn't sustained
and it wasn't this severe
what's the difference
well I think the first thing
has to do with the nature of what has
been found out about Illuminati because
we look at the scandals involving people
like uh Logan Paul or like PewDiePie and
honestly the stuff that they got in
trouble for
is more or less in line with their known
personalities with what everybody knows
about them like they got in trouble for
basically pushing it too far
you know in the case of PewDiePie
pushing a quote unquote edgy humor too
far and most people agreed that is too
far but it was still the kind of thing
he did so it was in line with what
people understood him to be and while
some people bounced off as a result of
that most people would just be like well
as long as he doesn't go that far again
I'll still be here and similarly uh with
someone like Blair white because
ultimately people were there for the
kinds of content that she made and she
continued to make that content and
honestly nobody was really going to her
for a hard-hitting well-researched news
people were going to her to get their
pre-existing opinions validated and she
continued to give them that and even the
horrendously terrible misreport lies
lies that she said about a number of
people I might have a slight personal
stake in that history but even with all
that
it still was very much in keeping with
the kind of stuff that she was known for
doing
it's not like people didn't know she
cherry-picked things and exaggerated
they did she just got caught doing it
more egregiously than usual but it all
was still in keeping with people's
understanding of her to take it out of
the realm of YouTube for in it for an
instant this I think is a big part of
why the Scandal that was supposed to
wreck Donald Trump in his initial
campaign for president the Access
Hollywood tape where he not only
admitted to but bragged about sexually
assaulting women
[Music]
it didn't sink him
because it wasn't in contrast with his
known Persona or personality
people knew he was a sexist pig
they were having it shoved in their face
just how much of one he was but
it's not it's a lot easier for people to
go okay so he's more of this thing than
I thought he was but I also did kind of
know and for those people just
roll with it and move on
Illuminati by contrast
she built her brand she built her
success
on analyzing
um and cataloging bad business practices
and the individual personalities behind
them personalities often that she would
document and note how they were volatile
manipulative and controlling and abusive
all the stuff she was accused of being
so when you have built your career on
calling out or documenting cases of
other people doing this stuff and it is
then revealed that you effectively do
essentially the same thing
that's going to hit you a lot harder
than you did something that people are
already mostly okay with but just did it
too much
this is in direct contradiction to who
people thought she was which makes it
more analogous uh in terms of YouTube to
somebody like Ned from the try guys now
the try guys is a slightly different
situation because he was not the only
person there and the other people
involved did have the ability to
effectively fire him which isn't the
case with Illuminati she is at the top
of that particular Mountain but the
basic fundamentals are very similar now
if you don't know everything that went
on with the try guys here's a real quick
breakdown of that
Ned was kind of known as the
relationship guy his role within the
group was the guy in a really super
stable relationship he built side
businesses outside of the try guys that
were basically monetizing his
relationship with his wife and like how
good and wonderful his marriage was that
was a huge part of his brand
and so when it came out that he not only
cheated but cheated with somebody who
worked for him
it's not that that is the most egregious
thing that anybody involved in YouTube
or anything else has ever done
it's that it is in complete
contradiction to what he had built his
entire brand on what he had built his
fan base on everyone understood him to
be this one thing
and that's not who he is
and that is what made him not viable to
stay on with the try guys I think more
so than the actual nuts and bolts of
what he did they may or may not have
gotten rid of him just for the power
imbalance of you know having an affair
with an employee and honestly they
should have gotten rid of him on that
basis alone but I bet you would have
been a much harder decision
if the idea of him being in a super
stable marriage wasn't such a huge part
of his image
I think they would have gotten a lot of
pushback at getting rid of him had that
up in the case now they still got some
but not a ton
because pretty much everyone looked at
how Ned had built his brand what he was
known for and then what he did and went
oh
well to hell with that then because the
basic Foundation of who he claimed to be
was destroyed
similarly with Illuminati
another example to step outside of
YouTube again would be Ellen DeGeneres
now Ellen DeGeneres was very well known
for cultivating a sense of kindness
be nice be sweet that was a huge part of
her image
then stuff started to come out about the
behind the scenes of her show and about
her being very unpleasant to work for
very nasty and just not the person
people thought she was and again Scandal
wise it basically just amounts to oh
your personality isn't what you project
out into the world which in terms of
sins of Hollywood pretty low
but again it's in direct contrast in
direct contradiction to what it was
people loved her for
because you look at people like Logan
Paul like PewDiePie like Channel awesome
which again is one I've talked about
before
they just got back to doing the thing
that people love them for which the
stuff that they got in trouble for is
not in direct contradiction to that so
to zoom in on channel awesome the way
that that company had been run
not good it wasn't good and they did
take a hit when
um things came out about how that
channel was run and a bunch of the
creators who have been part of that
channel spoke their truth yeah it wasn't
a good look and it did hit them in so
far as there have been this sense of
camaraderie between
um all the channels involved and that
that image got broken but Channel
awesome itself was still ultimately best
known for the Nostalgia Critic stuff
and so as long as they kept making
Nostalgia Critic
then the people who came there for that
as long as they still enjoyed it
we're likely to stick around and keep
watching it
which they did
again
not necessarily the same numbers and
with places like Channel awesome or some
of these others maybe
um a lot of other outlets or other
groups like don't want to work with them
anymore don't want to be associated with
them maybe they're not being asked to
you know guest spot on other stuff
nearly as much as they used to be
because it's like you're a bit of a
lightning rod but their core channels
they're fine they're all fine
Illuminati's isn't
and I'll be really curious to see how
long she can maintain the channel
because as I said she's not a one-person
show like this channel is a one-person
show the only thing that I don't do
myself in terms of what it is that you
see get put up on this channel is the
thumbnails
I come up with the ideas for the most
part on my own and if it's scripted I
script it myself and I shoot it I'm the
talent from the camera I edit it
it's me
Illuminati has a team
researchers writers editors she has
employees
employees that I don't know if she's
going to be able to continue to pay
assuming that she was giving them a fair
wage in the first place I can't imagine
she maintained the team that she has
which means that it might start to hit
the one thing that as I said she was
doing right which was to maintain her
content at the Quality that it had
already been and at the pace that it had
been
but assuming she's paying everybody
fairly
she's not going to be able to maintain
that
because without the corporate sponsors
and without the view numbers and the act
and getting the same Revenue she used to
get from YouTube itself
I can't imagine she's going to be able
to afford to support the entire team
that she'd had before which means either
quality is gonna drop or the pace at
which stuff comes out is gonna drop
and then it's a question of whether or
not that is so demotivating that she
just decides to stop that will come down
to her own personality and how she feels
about it I don't know but this is the
first time in a while in a scandal that
is short of like
you know being accused of being a nonce
um and you know that that kind of that
kind of stuff there aren't a lot of
scandals on YouTube that will kill you
completely there are accusations of
um predatory behavior towards
people too young for you that one can
get you
completely uh abandoned
but other than that assuming that your
channel isn't shut down for violations
of policy on the site and honestly those
are barely enforced but short of that
scandals that aren't uh the thing I just
implied and mentioned I sorry I can't
name it YouTube gets weird about it but
any kind of Scandal that is short of
that
they don't usually
hit this hard or last this long
and most of the time channels can bounce
back if they want to
I don't know if Illuminati can
if she was if her numbers were going to
start to bounce back
they should have by now
and it really makes it interesting to
talk about for that reason this is a
unique kind of a perfect storm of the
actual things that she's done not good
to be clear but also
on the lower end of uh as far as
potential Scandal on YouTube goes oh
well maybe not low end mid lane let's go
with middling as far as this kind of
thing goes
but
it's still hitting her a heck of a lot
harder and I think it's because of that
disconnect it is because of that
contradiction
between what everyone thought
she was
and who she is now proving to be
and as I said she kind of brought a lot
of this on herself
like
I get feeling the desire to respond to
some of the stuff that click said on
Twitter and that Wonderstruck said
but her approach to doing that which was
to throw a bunch of accusations at them
which would then naturally just prompt
them to respond to those maybe she
assumed they wouldn't have receipts and
that it that she'd be able to file
another look this is just that he said
she said thing believe who you want to
believe except they came in it with a
hell of a lot more evidence for their
side of the story than she had for hers
and maybe she just didn't account for
that or maybe as she has admitted to
already in this whole thing she acted
rashly and without properly thinking
through what she was doing
regardless of which is the case
she has undoubtedly had the biggest hand
in the destruction of her own business
because all of this is based off of her
own past behavior that is what's coming
forward and
even if that wasn't the case
she has made all of it worse by issuing
cease and desist including to somebody
who hadn't even done anything yet and
just her behavior and the picture that
has been painted and pretty much the
true floodgates didn't open until she
did her response video because that was
when people go oh okay now I'm throwing
everything I've got against you
she basically went oh no no I'm not the
bad guy they are
and they they came with bigger guns
she came with a peashooter they came
with cannons maybe she didn't realize
that they had them but nobody was
busting out the Cannons and pointing
them in her Direction until she started
throwing out her own accusations
the best thing she could have done
was to just acknowledge the uh the legal
eagle and the H bomber guy stuff and as
I said before just chalk up the stuff
from The Click because being like look
that's private and from a few years ago
and I really am I don't like that that
was shared but I'm not going to comment
on it to sort of play that I'm going to
rise above this thing now would that
have worked 100 percent
not necessarily
but I think it would have made it a lot
less likely that everyone would have
come out of the woodwork with their own
story
and so there we have the core of the
fall of Illuminati
she gave them reason to start talking
this site's Wild Man and no this is not
a single that I'm gonna start talking
about drama there's obviously ton of
drama that I don't talk about like I was
familiar with the try guys thing I still
didn't talk about it I considered it
briefly because I did find the Dynamics
of It kind of interesting but I felt
like that story had been picked clean by
the time I would have gotten to it this
as I said this thing has way longer legs
than I expected it to
but uh yeah
that's Illuminati
we'll see how much longer things stick
around in the state that they currently
in for her Channel
what are your thoughts on all this what
do you think was Blair's big mistake
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down that comes let's talk
about it patreon is how I'm able to do
this as my living even if you can't
support me that way there's links down
in the description for other things that
I do other platforms Etc and there's the
like the share the Subscribe
um I mentioned earlier the algorithm
doesn't always uh play fair and uh yeah
I'm feeling that off and on in the last
few years so there was that but it's
don't worry too much about it
what I want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid and you are loved
you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen Leo
the Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]
foreign